algunas veces la luz se comporta como
una onda y otras veces se comporta como
una partícula un ejemplo de esto es el
efecto fotoeléctrico de escrito por
einstein digamos que tenemos un pedazo
de metal sabemos que en el metal
hay algunos electrones aquí voy a
dibujar un electrón este electrón está
unido al metal porque es atraído por las
cargas positivas en el núcleo si hacemos
brillar una luz sobre el metal el tipo
correcto de luz con la frecuencia
correcta de luz podemos dejar fuera a
algunos electrones de manera que se dé
un flujo o corriente de electrones esto
es como la colisión de dos partículas si
vemos a la luz como una partícula aquí
voy a dibujar una partícula de luz que
llamamos fotón y que no tiene masa este
fotón va a impactar el electrón y si el
fotón tiene la suficiente energía puede
liberar al electrón así que queda suelto
vamos a mostrar al electrón moviéndose
en esta dirección con una velocidad de
y el electrón tiene una masa m y sabemos
que el electrón tiene una energía
cinética igual a un medio por m por b al
cuadrado este electrón libre ahora
llamado foto electrón un fotón crea un
foto electrón una partícula golpea a
otra partícula y si pensamos en esto en
términos de la física clásica pensaremos
en la conservación de la energía así que
la energía del fotón la energía de
entrada que le va a pasar a esta energía
bueno se necesita energía para liberar
al electrón que estaba enlazado a esta
energía para liberar al electrón le
llamamos a cero y el resto de la energía
se fue a la energía cinética del
electrón por lo que escribimos aquí la
energía cinética del foto electrón que
se produjo digamos que queremos despejar
la energía cinética de este foto
electrón lo que es algo sencillo de
hacer
la energía cinética es igual a la
energía del fotón
- la energía necesaria para liberar al
electrón de la superficie metálica que
llamamos es cero aunque quizás encuentre
nuestro escrito de forma diferente o con
diferentes símbolos pero esta es una
función de trabajo vamos a escribir la
función de trabajo y la función de
trabajo es diferente para cada metal es
la cantidad mínima de energía necesaria
para liberar al electrón por lo que
obviamente será diferente dependiendo
del metal que tengamos ahora que
comprendemos la idea general del efecto
fotoeléctrico hagamos un problema
si un fotón de longitud de onda de 525
nanómetros golpea cesio metálico con
función de trabajo 3.43 por 10 a la
menos 19 jules cuál es la velocidad del
photo electrón producido bueno queremos
saber la velocidad del foto electrón que
sabemos se esconde en la energía
cinética y también conocemos la función
de trabajo del metal es cero lo que no
conocemos es la energía del fotón así
que es lo que tenemos que calcular
primero así que la energía del fotón es
igual a h que es la constante de planck
multiplicada por la frecuencia que
usualmente se simboliza con new nos
piden la frecuencia en esta fórmula pero
el problema no está solo la longitud de
la onda así que tenemos que relacionar
la longitud de onda con la frecuencia y
eso está dado por sé que es la velocidad
de la luz
lambda por nio la velocidad de la luz es
igual a la longitud de onda por la
frecuencia y si queremos despejar la
frecuencia nos queda que es igual a la
velocidad de la luz dividida entre la
longitud de onda ahora podemos tomar
esto y sustituirlo aquí arriba
por lo que nos queda que esto es igual a
h porsche entre lambda y ahora si
podemos escribir los números h es la
constante de planck que es 6.626 por 10
a la menos 34 que es la velocidad de la
luz que es 2.998 por 10 a la 8 metros
por segundo y todo esto dividido entre
lambda que es la longitud de onda y es
525 por 10 a la menos 9 metros
ahora saquemos la calculadora para
encontrar cuánto es todo esto 6.626 por
10 a la menos 34
multiplicamos esto por la velocidad de
la luz multiplicamos esto por la
velocidad de la luz 2.998 por 10 a la 8
y al número resultante lo dividimos
entre 525 entre 525 por 10 a la menos 9
que es la longitud de onda y nos dan
3.78 por 10 a la menos 19 vamos a
escribir 3.78 por 10 a la menos 19 y las
unidades son jules pensemos un aumento
en este número tres puntos 78 por 10 a
la menos 19 es la energía del fotón y
esta energía es mayor que la función de
trabajo lo que significa que es un fotón
de alta energía que va a liberar al
electrón
esta cantidad de aquí es la energía
mínima necesaria para liberar al
electrón y hemos excedido esta energía
por lo que produciremos un electrón este
fotón tiene la energía suficiente para
producir un foto electrón ahora vamos a
encontrar la energía cinética del foto
electrón que se produjo y vamos a usar
esta ecuación de aquí arriba vamos a
hacer más espacio y reescribamos la
ecuación la energía cinética del
electrón es igual a la energía del fotón
- la función de trabajo pongamos los
números la energía del fotones 3.78 por
10 a la menos 19 yours
la función de trabajo que es 3.43 por 10
al menos 19 curso
saquemos de nuevo la calculadora
esto restamos la función de trabajo 3.43
por 10 a la menos 19
y nos dan 3.5 por 10 a las menos 20
euros
vamos a escribirlo 3.5 por 10 a la menos
20 yours
esta es la energía cinética del electrón
y sabemos que esto es igual a un medio
por la masa por la velocidad al cuadrado
nos preguntan la velocidad del photo
electrón producido pues ponemos los
números un medio por la masa del
electrón que es 9.11 por 10 a la menos
31 por la velocidad al cuadrado y esto
es igual a 3.5 por 10 a la menos 20
yours
de nuevo sacamos la calculadora este 3.5
por 10 a la menos 20 lo multiplicamos
por 2 y luego lo dividimos entre la masa
del electrón 9.11 por 10 a la menos 31
nos da este número y le sacamos la raíz
cuadrada y esto nos da la velocidad del
photo electrón que es 2.8 por 10 al
veamos los lugares decimales 1 2 3 4 5
así que es 2.8 por 10 a las 5 metros por
segundo la velocidad de nuestro foto
electrón producido es 2.8 por 10 a las 5
metros por segundo
y si aumentamos la intensidad de esta
luz tendremos más fotones que producirán
más fotos electrones pues cada fotón
producirá un foto electrón si tiene la
suficiente energía pensemos en el mismo
problema pero cambiemos la longitud de
onda veamos qué pasa si nuestra longitud
de onda ahora es de 625 nanómetros
para ahorrar tiempo no haremos los
cálculos pero lo único que tendríamos
que hacer es poner este número aquí
arriba en lugar del 525 para calcular la
energía si hacemos esto y ponemos 625
por 10 a la menos 9 tendremos y les doy
la respuesta directa para ahorrarnos
tiempo 3.2 por 10 a la menos 19 euros y
esto es menor que la función de trabajo
recuerden que la función de trabajo es
la cantidad mínima de energía necesaria
para liberar al electrón de su enlace
con el metal y como esto es menor que la
función de trabajo significa que no
tendremos un foto electrón necesitamos
un fotón de alta energía para producir
un foto electrón
y no importa si aumentamos la intensidad
así que aunque tengamos muchos fotones
en esta longitud de onda aún no
tendremos ningún foto electrón esta es
la idea del efecto fotoeléctrico que es
explicado al tomar a la luz como una
partícula